how when did you start this project when
was the first I first pitched it I don't
know when the first German the idea was
but I know that I first pitched it to
John Lasseter at Pixar in September of
2011 okay so we've been working on this
movie for the past six years okay and do
you what's what what do you now think I
know how creativity can be what do you
now think was the germ or that were what
was the catalyst that got it
past the point of an idea into let's do
this well after we finished making Toy
Story 3 I started thinking about what I
wanted to do next and I actually kicked
around a few different ideas John often
likes to have us pitch him like three
different ideas so we're not putting all
our eggs in one basket and one of those
three ideas that I pitched to John was
the idea of telling a story set against
dia de Muertos we didn't really know the
story then at that point the thing that
I pitched to him was a very different
story than we ended up making but but
from the beginning you know I was
inspired by this beautiful tradition of
dia de Muertos and the when I spent time
really learning about the details of the
tradition and how how people observe it
I discovered how central family is the
idea family to día de Muertos it's all
about family remembrance and you know
the obligation that we have to remember
our loved ones after they're gone and
most importantly to pass their stories
along to the next generation so that
their memories are never forgotten and
the more that I learned that and the
more that it kind of those ideas were
placed maybe some of my preconceptions
about what dia de Muertos was all about
the more that I realized that we had the
potential to tell a really rich story
that not only had the potential to be a
really entertaining film and really
funny colorful hopefully visually
dazzling musical but the family aspect
of it is what convinced me that the film
could have a real strong emotional core
as we're always looking for that and our
idea is something that's gonna have a
lot of emotion so who is your next
collaborator was it Darla as it was she
assigned but when you
if Darla was with me from the beginning
okay very beginning I signed myself you
assigned yourself so when you're brought
I do when you were brought on to this
project what what was it and then what
was the process of kind of taking it to
the next level and redeveloping it well
yeah we start very with teeny tiny
little teams and we sit in these rooms
for years on it and just working out the
story and and really it was Leslie
mentioned it was after we were working
on Toy Story 3 and it was Lee and I and
our head of story Jason Katz and the
next the first thing we did was we
jumped on a plane and went down to
Mexico we took many trips down to Mexico
but that trip was very very inspiring
and the most amazing and beautiful thing
was the generosity warmth kindness and
inspiration of the people we hung out
with and it was very important to leave
from early on he just kept saying I just
want to spend more time with the
families and I want to get to know their
stories and so anyway we we were
fortunate enough to to do that you
mentioned the word musical and I'm
trying to think this is a 19th Pixar
film is this like the first thing that's
the closest to a musical for pick I
think it's the closest we've had so far
because it's just wall-to-wall and it
has so many different levels of music so
you know Michael you obviously had the
score that you were worried about and
the you know tell me I wasn't so worried
about it yeah well yeah that was your
job too but it doesn't ever seem worried
but there's also the idea of bringing in
these songs and also you have a specific
culture and a culture that's layered
with many different types of music could
you talk about the beginning the music
and then bring who came in with the
partnership and how all the different
pieces fit together well you know on a
film like this when you're dealing with
songs usually the songs have to be
written first and and I also want to
mention you know the song in the film
you know remember me those two guys
aren't here tonight Robert and Kristen
Lopez who who wrote that song and I got
to give it up to them because they they
did such an amazing job with that song
but so the songs usually come first now
and scores usually last but in this case
I came in
much earlier than I would have because
it wasn't just score it was also source
music so if he's running down the street
we wanted it to feel like he was really
running down the street in in this town
in Mexico
what would you hear you know you there
be musicians playing there would be a
radio over here there would be something
going on there
we had to do all of that music so they
could animate to that so that was done
very early on and all of that music that
what we call source music was recorded
down in Mexico so we were planning this
big trip to go down to Mexico City
record with Mexico City's finest
Mexico's finest musicians do all of this
source music I was so excited about it
and then I got pulled out of that trip
because that's when this was last year's
when star wars happened and so I was
thrown onto that and I had to then
Jermaine kind of took over and headed
down to Mexico City and did an amazing
job producing all of the music that you
heard in the streets and that the bands
are playing and all of that so I I wrote
it handed it off and then there's also
some traditional music in there as well
which I know that she can speak to and
talk about that so it was that was first
then came the score after all that work
was done so Jermaine I think you're
responsible correct me if I'm wrong for
making me smile right off the bat with
the wouldn't you wish upon a star being
having a mariachi field and then you
also wrote a couple of songs with Adrian
Poco Loco and a couple so could you talk
about working as a team to try and make
this whole be a cohesive and arranging
and having him go off him to do Star
Wars and at the same time I think you
were communicating with each other you
know by Skype or whatever during that
yeah I was getting a lot of videos
jealous I was sitting on the stage
recording but I wanted to be there okay
well the logo was one of the first
things I did which was really fun to do
which was my assignment was make it
sound like symphonic Mexico and so we
you know I tried a couple versions and
that one's stuck but then I was at I did
some Arrangements on remember me with
Kristen anderson-lopez and Robert Lopez
and then eventually started writing
which was a wonderful
opportunity to and Adrienne wrote such
poetic and beautiful lyrics that it was
so easy to work with him I loved what he
sent and I found it quite genuine and
just inspired by the story we would have
all these conversations with you know
Lee Darla Adrienne and we would just
talk about what they wanted in the scene
and and I would send multiple you know
versions of demos and then come back at
notes and un poco local was one song
that we also took to Mexico and recorded
which was really fun we have the one of
the top high dojo groups called mono
Blanco it's also playing on that and
also we put some mariachis on it was
really fun to work together what I loved
about the process of recording in Mexico
is that you bring in these you know
expert musicians but but you also allow
you want the music to be inspired by the
story but you allow the story to be
inspired by the music - so instances
where in Poco Loco
Jermaine kind of in in in her demo
started adding sums up at the Auto
this-this-this footwork that she
recorded you know knockin shoes against
wooden boards for the demo and that
started to inspire like oh we could have
this we could incorporate this into the
character and and and pull Hector on
stage and have him start dancing and and
bring a little bit of that you know
Mexican folk dancing into this film and
in all of it just lends itself to a
richness and a reality and a history
that I think makes the film feel
timeless but but of a certain place and
and of a certain culture Lee talked
about the animation of skeletons which i
think is a big difference for this film
and something you guys see always seem
to have something that you tackle that
hasn't really been done before so it
seems like it would be simple but on the
other hand I understand it isn't could
you explain that a little bit sure there
wasn't any one thing on this film that
was kind of the the big you know
headline technical challenge to solve it
was more that this is a big film you
know it's
just it's it's enormous in scope and it
feels very epic actually yeah I mean
it's a relatively small story but it's
set against this this epic landscape we
had to design and build the whole land
of the Dead which was an enormous
undertaking and then populate that land
of the Dead with thousands and thousands
of skeleton characters that needed to
have clothing and like lots of things
that are you know in small numbers
aren't terribly difficult these days to
do in computer graphics but we just it
was at such a scale that that ended up
being the challenge on this but that
being said the the skeletons themselves
were a challenge there was more a design
challenge than a technical challenge we
knew they were gonna be skeleton
characters in the film from early on and
we wanted to design skeletons that
weren't scary or off-putting because in
my mind they were just characters in the
in the story they were in some cases
Miguel's own family members so we didn't
want them to be frightening in any way I
also made a choice very early on to give
them eyeballs which right that's kind of
weird very for skeletons to have eyes
but now that you've seen the think about
it too much I just knew in that scene
where Miguel and act are down in the
cenote in the cave I knew I was going to
be in a big closeup of Ector with the
camera pushing in and I needed the
audience to be emotionally connected
with him and to see him as a as a as a
person with a soul and I couldn't
imagine doing that without eyes and so
we made that decision early on and then
beyond that it was just there were
technical things about figuring out how
to you know have the skeletons be able
to break apart and come back together
and that was really hard and there was a
core group a small group of animators
that were really good at that so we
would give them the hardest shots
but yeah thank you very much